del lunes la misma historia se
desarrolla en el parlamento de italia
día tras día se cuentan las papeletas
para elegir el próximo presidente del
país y la conclusión es la misma
no se alcanzó la mayoría absoluta de los
integrantes de la asamblea
es necesario proceder a una nueva
votación
los partidos de izquierda dicen que el
trabajo debería recaer en el actual
primer ministro mario draghi quien ha
sido aclamado por traer estabilidad al
país pero muchos temen que un cambio
abrupto del primer ministro a presidente
podría llevar al frágil gobierno de
coalición en italia al límite otros
bloques políticos se pelean por
encontrar un planeta el viernes los
partidos de derecha apoyaron a la
presidenta del senado elisabetta castle
a ti no lo habíamos candidata en cuanto
dos no la elegimos por ser mujer sino
como personalidad institucional y
profesional de confianza funcionaria
estatal con experiencia en el ámbito
judicial territorio de los datos no
experiencia y magistratura en la boca
tuvo russell a ti miembro del partido
forza italia de berlusconi es conocida
por su oposición al aborto y las uniones
entre personas del mismo sexo los
partidos de izquierda tildan su
nominación de error que la obtuvo solo
382 votos muy por debajo de los 505
necesarios para ganar
matar a él
matara en la
mientras tanto partes del movimiento
cinco estrellas se están presionando
para que el presidente sergio mataré la
se quede pero el hombre de 80 años
insiste en que no quiere un segundo
mandato se acaba el tiempo para que el
parlamento encuentre su sustituto el
periodo de mataré la finalizará el 3 de
febrero